tim is wearing sensors recording from my
ear brain activity and we're recording
heart rate and recording movement from
the chest we're streaming this to the
cloud where we're translating this into
measures of my relaxation level my heart
rate we can get heart rate variability
we can get variety of states that are
related to the types of signals that I
can get here from this in the air sensor
and from my heart rate monitor and all
that happen in the cloud and coming back
to my mobile device so we've got our EEG
our ECG our heart activity my relaxation
score actigraph e so if I move around a
little bit it's gonna go up it gets all
red and I'll be still and then my heart
rate and so we can take all of this and
we can do something kind of cool like
this because all my data is going
through neuro scale hey Alexa ask neuro
scale for my current relaxation level
your current relaxation level is 20%
you're pretty pumped up if you feel like
relaxing a bit we could do some
meditation exercises together and that's
an example of how we can integrate
something like Amazon Alexa through the
neuro scale platform connect that to my
brain and my heart my body do something
useful like asking Alexa what's my state
how am I feeling right now but it could
also be your light could be your car it
could be any other Internet connected
device and you can build that kind of
application on the neuro scale platform
[Music]